-Here's how it works
-Okay.
-We are going to take turn
drawing one of these cards
Each card has five totally
random questions on it.
-Okay.
-One person asks the question.
The other person has to answer
each question
as soon as it's asked --
I mean, like, immediately.
-Immediately.
-Yep.
And it doesn't matter if
the answer is right or wrong
It just has to be the very first
thing that pops in your head
-No time to ruminate.
-No rumination. No.
Seth, because you're the guest
I'll read your questions first
-Okay. Gotcha. So, give myself
about two minutes for each one
-[ Chuckles ] Here we go.
Are we changing the lights
We are.
-Oh, good.
I think faster when it's dark.
♪♪♪♪
-Why were you late for brunch?
-Because I hurt my knee!
-What's the German word
for potato chip?
-Neinschenfrien!
-What does Brenda look like?
-Well, better
than she used to look.
-Laugh without smiling.
-[ Imitates laugh ]
-Whisper your darkest secret
-[ Whispers ]
I'm not really hear.
[ Laughter ]
-That's it right there.
It works like that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the way it is.
Seth, it is my turn.
Whenever you're ready.
-Okay.
-Choose a card.
Okay, ready?
-Yep.
-Why did you eat my toothpaste
-Because I needed it.
-What rhymes with umbrella
-Frumbrella. [ Laughs ]
-Why is there so much meat
in the garbage?
-Because Gary put it there
-Yell the name of a vegetable.
-Kumquat!
-Do sharks go to heaven?
-No.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
I thought it was going to en
on kumquat.
I didn't know there was
another all right.
-All right, it's time
for the final round here.
You get a card,
and I get a card.
Okay, in this round,
we both pick up a card
with the same set of questions
We'll ask and answer them one at
a time going back and forth.
Ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Here we go. "Think fast."
Round 3.
I go first.
[ Clears throat ]
Why are bugs so small?
-Because if they were bigger
they would be whales.
-What's the cool toy everyon
wants this Christmas?
-Uh, they got to get a Keebler
[ Laughter ]
What's in the piñata?
-All the candies!
Why do you love your dentist
-Because of the candies.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, how big is the big monkey?
-As big as the biggest monkey!
What does the food taste -
-Uh, what?
-What does the food taste like
-Oh, sorry. Thank you.
-It's just bland,
but with a hint of cilantro.
What is the worst smell?
-The smell
of the biggest monkey.
Give me a compliment.
-I love your style.
-Thank you.
-Give me an insult.
-I love when you say
you love my style,
I can tell you're lying.
How do you say California
backward?
-Cafinoria.
[ Laughter ]
There you have it. That wa
"Think Fast" with Seth Meyers.
His stand-up special,
"Lobby Baby"
is available on Netflix.
Check it out.